a rudy giuliani who was recently accused
of being drunk on election night during
which he told donald trump just claimed
that you won and gave him all sorts of
other authoritarian advice that led to
months and months and really at this
point years of trump and others
insisting that trump actually won rudy
giuliani initially tweeted that he was
not drunk on election night and he has
quietly deleted those tweets the obvious
speculation is
rudy deleted the tweets because there's
going to be undeniable evidence that
rudy was actually drunk out of his mind
on election night so um let's go through
this piece by piece
rudy giuliani deletes tweets denying he
was drunk on election night
explosive claim was made by fellow
campaign staffer so as a reminder i know
many of you already saw this clip one of
the big things at the start of the
second day of hearings with the trump
riot committee was liz cheney explaining
that rudy giuliani in an inebriated
state was the one telling trump just
declare victory you will hear first-hand
testimony that the president's campaign
advisers urged him to await the counting
of votes and not to declare victory on
election night
the president understood even before the
election that many more biden voters had
voted by mail because president trump
ignored the advice of his campaign
experts and told his supporters only to
vote in person donald trump knew before
the election that the counting of those
mail-in ballots in several states would
not begin until late in the day and
would not be complete for multiple days
this was expected reported and widely
known
you will also hear testimony that
president trump rejected the advice of
his campaign experts on election night
and instead followed the course
recommended by an apparently inebriated
rudy giuliani right to just claim he won
and insist that the vote counting stop
to falsely claim everything was
fraudulent yep okay so
initially rudy giuliani
tweeted
refuting denying these claims rudy
tweeting
not long ago quote i am disgusted and
outraged at the outright lie by jason
miller and bill stephen i was upset that
they were not prepared for the massive
cheating as well as other lawyers around
the president i refused all alcohol that
evening my favorite drink diet pepsi is
the false testimony from miller and
stephen because i yelled at them are
they being paid to lie
well rudy giuliani has now deleted those
tweets
rudy giuliani has deleted two tweets
in which
the former mayor and attorney for trump
denied being drunk as votes rolled in on
election night and advising the
president to declare victory the two
tweets disappeared from giuliani's
timeline sometime tuesday evening
what is the most simple explanation for
this well the simplest explanation is
someone is going to come forward with
specific knowledge of rudy being drunk
that night either it's video he's he
said very not only did see here's the
problem not only did rudy deny being
drunk he said he refused all alcohol so
because rudy went above and beyond in
his denial if there is any evidence that
he had any alcohol that night he now is
a liar you could say i was not drunk i
had a drink i was not drunk and then if
someone comes forward and says here's a
picture of rudy with a drink you're not
necessarily an obvious liar rudy still
is a liar of course but you're not
necessarily an obvious liar here it's a
different thing where rudy said i
refused alcohol the entire evening now
as a as a reminder
we're not making fun of alcoholism if
that is something rudy struggles with
there are widespread reports that during
the trump presidency
uh the schedulers around trump started
booking rudy giuliani for morning tv
shows rather than evening because it
turned out that in the evenings he would
allegedly show up drunk after having a
bunch of drinks at dinner uh we also
have videos like this one which again i
know some of you have seen but where he
he genuinely seems completely wasted
can imagine tony blanken or miley
how's that guy a general
jesus
the other day he said that the bagram
air force base is not strategically
important
i wanted to grab his what he had five
stars 10 stars 12 stars he has so many
stars that coming up into his ears
i wanted to grab his stars shove it down
his throat and say it's 400 miles from
china [ __ ]
china yeah so anyway the real issue here
is there were people on election night
around trump telling him the truth which
is you lost but trump ignored all of
them and just accepted what he wanted to
hear from an allegedly drunk rudy
giuliani which is you you probably won
just go out and declare victory that's
the really crazy part of the story
rudy deleting the tweets just points
more in the direction of the testimony
being accurate my audience knows i read
i read a ton of books i read nonfiction
i read fiction at night i'm always
trying to consume information and the
truth is i don't have the time to read
every non-fiction book that i would like
to read one thing i do not have time to
add to what i'm reading in paper form is
more history but i want to know about
history and that's where our sponsor
blinkist comes in blinkist doesn't
replace reading books cover to cover the
way i love to do but for example with
everything going on right now with roe v
wade i wanted more of a detailed history
of roe v wade in the united states
so on blinkist i was able to get a
15-minute condensed audiobook of the
mary ziegler book abortion and the law
in america roe v wade to the present and
in 15 minutes i get a great overview
blinkist also has slide presentations
that will take you about 15 minutes to
go through so
it's not to replace reading it's in
addition to for me you get the key
takeaways from blinkist from the books i
would certainly otherwise miss out on
you can try blinkist for free for seven
days and get a 25 discount off of a
subscription at blinkist.com pacman the
link is down below